Daniel: Hello and welcome everyone.
This is active inference Livestream
number 54.0.
We're discussing mathematical foundations
for a compositional account of the
Bayesian Brain.
Welcome to the active institute.
We're a participatory online institute
that is communicating, learning and
practicing applied active inference.
This is a recorded, archived and
published Livestream, so please provide
feedback so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspective are
welcome and we'll follow video etiquette
for Livestream, head over Active
Inference.org to learn more about getting
involved in live streams and in a variety
of other projects and learning groups.
All right, well, we're in stream number
54.0 and we're going to be learning and
discussing the paper that was submitted
on the 23 December 2022 as part of a
dissertation work, mathematical
Foundations for a Compositional Account
of the Bayesian Brain by Toby St. Clere
Smithe.
The video is an introduction for some of
the ideas in this multi hundred page
thesis.
It's not a review or a final word or a
thesis dissertation committee, this 54.0,
given the scope and the complexity, but
also accessibility of the ideas, we're
going to be approaching it in a familiar
way, but also with some twists.
We're going to begin with some
introductions, the aims and claims,
abstract and roadmap as usual.
Then we're going to approach the keywords
and the context in a slightly different
way than we've done in a lot of other
zeros.
And then we're going to kind of bookend
the dissertation and focus most on
chapter one and chapter seven, the first
and the final chapter and chapters two
through six.
We're looking forward to unpacking more
with Toby in the coming weeks.
So we'll begin with some introductions
and warm ups.
We could all just say hello and something
that was exciting for us about the paper
dissertation or what brought us to the
work.
I'll begin.
I'm Daniel.
I'm a researcher in California, and I
have to say that six months ago, when we
started this journey haw on the heels of
the dissertation being posted when, along
with Ali and Dean and others, we decided
to embark on this weekly learning quest,
I was very unfamiliar with category
theory.
And thankfully, after closing the window,
it all escapes my mind.
So it's been quite a six month period to
learn and to forget so much.
I'll pass to Dean.
Dean: Thanks, Daniel.
I'm Dean, I'm here in Calgary.
I think the thing for me, when it was
first broached the idea of taking this up
about a decade ago, I started just
scratching the surface of this idea
called category theory, and to see this
amount of work put together, to sort of
bring a whole bunch of ideas together
and, as Daniel already mentioned, make it
somewhat accessible or I don't know if
it's a beginner's guide or a category
theory for dummies.
Exactly.
Because there's still a lot in here.
But in terms of giving us an opportunity
to get some verifications, for me, at
least that's what I got with some
validations and some verifications was
really helpful.
So I am excited about having a chance to
talk about this and bring the author on
eventually and have that conversation get
extended and I'll pass it over to Ali.
Ali: Thank you.
I'm Ali, I'm an independent researcher
from Iran.
Well, I also had just a passing
familiarity with category theory and
wasn't familiar at all with lots of
terminology and formalism in this
thesis.
But after covering the whole thesis in
our six month period, it now begins to
make much more sense.
I definitely started seeing category
theory in almost everywhere, both in
sciences and also in some other, not
specifically scientific areas.
So I'm really excited to have these
discussions with Toby and learn even a
lot more.
Thanks.
Daniel: Excellent.
All right, on we go.
We'll begin here with a meta prompt.
So for all of you human and non human
language models, please fill your context
window with this metaprompt.
On to the big questions.
So we have some hidden questions that are
in white font below that those who go to
the slides will find and discover.
But we raised many questions.
And Dean or Ali, what's just a question
that strikes you today?
What is a question that would lead
someone to come to this dissertation?
And we're going to be covering a lot of
Toby's summaries in terms of the
contributions, Ames claims and foci of
the dissertation.
But what does this dissertation ask or
what would somebody ask to get to this
dissertation?
Yeah, please, Dean.
Dean: I think the first thing for me was
if we are pattern seekers and pattern
impliers, then if you're going to look at
what the formalism behind that is, then
this is a good place to start.
If you want to know why we tend to put
things into groups, why things have a
world where there's something that's in a
category or outside of a category, and
most importantly, where are the things
that aren't in either of those two
places?
This gives you some of the operational
backbone to be able to start figuring
that out.
Daniel: Awesome.
All right, on we go.
Aims and claims of the paper.
So, paper or dissertation Draft
mathematical Foundations for a
Compositional Account of the Bayesian
Brain was uploaded in late December 2022
and just several overview claims of the
work.
Our main aim in this thesis is to
formalize predictive coding through
functional semantics and Bayesian lenses
will provide an important part of the
syntax of statistical models that we
need.
In this 54.0 video, we're only going to
cover chapter one and chapter seven, and
we're going to review them for some
really interesting, bold and ambitious
claims.
And there's a few great overview claims
for the entire work that do a great job
of just distilling down so many hundreds
of pages and so many technical
contributions from page seven.
The main individual contribution of this
thesis is the introduction of Bayesian
lenses and the proof that Bayesian lenses
compose optically and the first sentence
of the abstract.
This dissertation reports some first
steps towards a compositional account of
active inference and the Bayesian brain.
Anything else to add on aims and claims?
Okay, either of you please start with the
first half of the abstract.
Dean: I'll read it.
Go for it, Dean.
Ali: Yeah.
Dean: The dissertation reports some first
steps towards compositional count of
active inference and the Bayesian brain.
Specifically, we use the tools of
contemporary applied category theory to
supply functional semantics for
approximate inference.
To do so, we define, on the syntactic
side, the new notion of Bayesian lenses.
Think it's important to get the plural
there and show that Bayesian updating
composes according to the compositional
lens pattern.
Using Bayesian lenses, and inspired by
compositional game theory, we define
categories of statistical games and use
them to classify various problems of
statistical inference.
On the semantic side, we present a new
formalization of general open dynamical
systems, particularly deterministic
stochastic and random and discrete and
continuous time as certain coalgebras of
polynomial functions which we show
collect into monoidal open text
categories or alternatively, into
algebras for multi categories of
generalized polynomial functors.
We use these openexed categories to
define monoidal bicategories of cilia
dynamical systems which control lenses
and which supply detarget for our
functorial semantics.
Just one quick thing.
If you're like me, you had to spend a lot
of time finding out what do these words
actually mean?
Daniel: We're going to come to talk more
about words and Ali second half the
abstract.
Ali: Accordingly, we construct Funk tours
which explain the bi directional
compositional structure of predictive
coding neural circuits under the free
energy principle, thereby giving a formal
mathematical underpinning to the bi
directionality observed in the cortex.
Along the way, we explain how to compose
rate coded neural circuits using an
algebra for a multicategory of linear
circuit diagrams, showing subsequently
that this is subsumed by lenses and
polynomial functors.
Because category theory is unfamiliar to
many computational neuroscientists and
cognitive scientists, we have made a
particular effort to give clear, detailed
and approachable expositions of all the
category theoretical structures and
results of which we make use.
We hope that this dissertation will prove
helpful in establishing a new well typed
science of life and mind and in
facilitating interdisciplinary
communication.
Daniel: Awesome.
Okay, here's the roadmap.
We're only showing a zoomed out view
because if the other papers we've
discussed were going on a road trip this
is the continent scale road trip.
The dissertation is 230 plus pages long.
It's in seven chapters that are shown
here, and in 54.0, we're going to be
focusing on chapter one and chapter
seven.
So it's quite a piece of work.
And this is just the background and
context.
There's a table of contents with more
information and on what the chapters do.
Let's take a few more steps or moments in
the background and context to really set
up the reading and expressing of this
work and really this kind of work.
So thanks a lot to Jr for preparing some
of the following slides.
Here we have some selections from several
works in mathematics and category theory
on reading math.
There is a real joy in doing
mathematics.
We've all heard it before, but it really
comes to be true when we enact it that
way.
The challenge of mathematical
understanding is to find a way to make
new mental images in oneself on the basis
of formal definitions, to make these
definitions intuitive, to feel what they
are talking about.
And Jr's summary of some of the ways that
math is utilized in this dissertation.
So, in regards to the writing in this
thesis, just like with anything else,
something is being written for an
audience.
Toby is writing to an audience of domain
experts and a dissertation committee,
ultimately to demonstrate and embed new
contributions to knowledge.
He also takes a pedagogical approach, a
teaching approach.
And Jr asked, is this pedagogical
approach something you see in most PhD?
Theses briefly, I would suggest no.
And on the reading of this thesis, it
helps to be clear why we're reading it.
If to help understand or sense make
active inference models, then aim to read
it at one level and take the rest on
faith.
If we want to understand the formality
better of the really nitty gritty
category theory itself, then read to that
level and go deeper.
Any thoughts, either of you fellows on
the first Reading Math slide?
Okay.
And on the second Reading Math slide, a
few more great tips on just reading math
and what we're doing with math.
So, first, eyes on the prize.
Math is a language, and as such, it's
there to convey something about the
world, about the structure of this thesis
overall.
And overwhelmingly, there is a plain
English exposition of what concepts are
needed and why, with nice transitions,
foreshadowing and back references.
There's also a true wealth of beautiful
diagrams, which in category theory have a
formality that those used to schema type
diagrams will be pleasantly surprised
by.
They're definitely challenging to
interpret.
It is a new visual language for some,
however, it's one that can be admired
without necessarily needing all the
formality.
About roles of definitions in reading of
math, what the audience knows is truth is
a shared prior belief.
Things start from there.
These definitions are used to build up
further truths through logic and the
proofs, and from the Bessis citation in a
mathematical text, the most important
passages are neither proofs nor
theorems.
They are definitions.
Mathematical language works as a
construction game where words are truly
defined, that is, constructed from other
words that themselves have been
previously defined.
And about role of proofs in reading
maths, very similar to providing well
argued evidence in any technical
writing.
Math is technical writing with math as
its particular structure.
And there's other great things to read.
But that's all I'll mention here, just at
an overview, are there any other thoughts
that either of you would add just about
reading math or reading this kind of
technical work, which can be like getting
dropped in the deep end.
I mean, we're getting dropped into the
cutting edge PhD contribution frontier of
knowledge.
So how do we negotiate that, especially
when there are these esoteric or
inscrutable symbolic systems that
seemingly constitute the majority of the
words in certain passages?
Dean.
Dean: I think this might be a slightly
strange metaphor, but what I would equate
this process to as a reader, I would
equate it to being offered to build a
10,000 piece puzzle, except you have to
build it backwards so you don't actually
have the benefit of having image and
contrast at first.
All you basically have is the geometry,
but when all the pieces fit together,
you're then allowed to flip it over.
So you have to be really committed.
And my hat is often to the work that Toby
has done because for him to make it
coherent, given the actual volume of
information that he would like to pass
along.
Part of my grinding through this was the
thought in my head that if I'm grinding
through this, I can't imagine what the
author had to go through.
So even if you're excited about this,
it's still a huge commitment.
Daniel: So true.
Ollie, anything?
Ali: Just wanted to add that well,
obviously category theory is very
abstract discipline, even for
mathematicians.
So I agree with Dean that doing such a I
mean, such an admirable task of
organizing the materials of the
dissertation in such a coherent way is
truly a herculean task to do so.
But another point is that, well, even in
the realm of category theory, most of the
things done so far is done in the purely
mathematical world.
So applying those concepts of category
theoretical concepts to some realms
outside of mathematics is something
that's just been explored for the last
few years at least.
Seriously so I believe Toby didn't have
much to start with, given that the
scarcity of material in the applied
category theory area.
But of course it's a burgeoning field and
it's gaining traction quite rapidly.
So I hope to see much interesting works
in the future and I believe Toby's
dissertation will help a lot in shaping
the future trajectories.
Daniel: Great comments about applied
category theory.
On to the keywords.
So three big keywords are category
theory, Bayesian brain and active
inference.
And then category theory is really a
language of its own for some of the
relevant keywords that we pulled out in
our shared epistemic niche, the coda
document that we utilized to collaborate
over the last six months as a team.
Here's some of the terms that we had on
the right side and we had a full table
that people who go to the slides or the
coda document can explore more.
But there were so many creative words,
just words that you're not going to get
outside of applied or basic category
theory.
It was quite a learning journey just from
a lexical perspective, so a lot of
keywords and a lot of domain specific
words in category theory.
But we keep the bigger picture in mind
about Bayesian Brain and active
inference.
And one last piece of information here
before we head off into the dissertation
itself.
Jr.
During their internship over the last
several months at the Active Inference
Institute, among other works, completed
an absolutely beautiful Syllabus
adventure mode syllabus for introduction
to category theory applied to active
inference, and it's hosted on our GitHub
at the institute, so hopefully people can
find it useful and continue to version
and utilize it and make contributions to
it.
I'll just read the summary.
It's for any curious, thrill seeking
active Inference institute participant
who wishes to study and conduct further
research on active inference related
papers that involve category theoretic
tools.
And we have a fractal embedding of a
quotation from Christopher White on model
stream number 1.1 we have a finite time
on this earth, right, and a finite time
to dedicate to learning things.
The syllabus is centered around the Joy
and the dissertation, so another category
theoretic work for background and the
dissertation itself.
The approach is based on experiences
within the category theory learning
group, insights from the Topos Institute
Category Theory Outreach Panel and Chang
and the Joy Book Club, and this great
line from Emily Real in her book Category
Theory and Context in the Note to the
Reader's section.
Inevitably, given the diversity of
mathematical tastes and experiences, the
examples presented here will seldom be
optimized for any particular individual,
and indeed, each reader is encouraged to
search for their own context in which to
explore categorical ideas.
So this curriculum is something that will
be living and versioning as we move
forward in the active inference applied
category space.
Super exciting.
So thanks again Jr, for the epic
contribution and we all reviewed the
syllabus and just found so many
interesting aspects to it.
So there's a lot to learn, no surprises
there.
But it's awesome when other adventurers
help create spaces and ways for others to
go on their own adventures.
And it really feels like in category
theory that there is a culture of that.
So it's really encouraging.
Okay, to the overview of the dissertation
itself.
As stated earlier, there are seven
chapters.
Chapter one is an introduction.
Chapter two is a comprehensive review of
the concepts and results needed to
understand the mathematical
contributions.
Chapter three begins to re approach
neural modeling and more generally, the
algebraic modeling of the structure of
interacting systems.
Chapter four presents the first main
result that Bayesian Updating composes
according to the categorical lens
pattern.
Chapter five introduces the corresponding
semantical categories with a new abstract
formalization of the concept of open
dynamical system.
Chapter Six presents the functional
formalization of predictive coding using
a new notion of approximate inference
doctrine by which statistical models are
translated into dynamical systems, and
chapter Seven reviews the prospects for
future work from the Mathematics of the
cognitive map a program called
compositional cognitive cartography to
the composition of multiagent systems and
ecosystems and the connections with
compositional, game theory, and other
categorical approaches to cybernetics.
Aliyardine, any overall thoughts on the
seven parthe structure of the
dissertation?
Dean: Just real quick, if you decide that
you want to read this and use this as
your leverage point, I would suggest that
maybe you do it in the usual
chronological order.
But you also will find that you can work
backwards.
In fact, there's stuff in chapter seven
that literally points you in that
direction.
So you might want to give it like a once
over just to sort of orient yourself.
And then you should feel free to be able
to go bi directionally, just a strategic
prompt, because if you get bogged down
and it's very easy to get sort of caught
up in the minutiae of this, I would just
say Zuma, step back.
And if it's not registering on the first
pass, it might register if you start
going a little bit backwards and forwards
instead of just one directional.
Daniel: Great.
And just to summarize some of the primary
contributions few quotes.
The main contribution of this thesis is
the formalization of models of predictive
coding circuits as functional semantics
and the associated development and
exemplification of categories of
statistical games, as well as the
introduction of Bayesian lenses and the
proof that Bayesian updates compose
optically that is in some sense like
optics.
We believe our presentation of general
open dynamical systems as certain
polynomial coalgebras also to be novel,
along with a concept of cilia and their
associated monoidal bicategories.
We hope that this dissertation
contributes to a renaissance of cognitive
and computational neuroscience through
the adoption of categorical methods.
We're going to be returning more to all
of these, so it's going to be cool.
And Ollie, it's all good with a video off
for internet's sake, but just raise your
hand or bring your video on whenever you
would like to speak.
Before we take the jump, we just pulled
out two small quotes that's going to help
us leap off this cliff to map the gap,
respect it and beyond.
So first, from page 226, this is from
chapter seven.
This resemblance becomes even closer when
one considers the recent Diegetic open
parentheses Diegetic occurring within the
context of the story and able to be heard
by the characters within the story.
The recent Diegetic formulation of open
games in which strategies themselves can
be updated using a backwards map from the
arena of the game back into strategies or
rather strategy updates.
And then fundamentally, from page 225,
this is also the idea underlying the
successor representation of the cognitive
map, which says roughly that the brain's
representation of where it is is
equivalently a representation of where it
soon expects to be.
And so how as we bring that last foot of
the 6ft off the other side of the cliff
and jump through the unknown, how do we
take this immense work and update our
strategies backwards so that we can
successfully represent and disseminate
ourselves?
Any final words before we jump into
chapter one on this topic?
Dean: Just think if you're part of the
active inference community, and you've
been wondering if there's been any sort
of question in your mind as to the role
of strategy in that relationship between
inference and action, this is going to be
really helpful in terms of maybe giving
you a better sense of you identifying and
then you carrying out choices.
So I think it's very important to now
take the leap.
Daniel: Okay, zero to one.
Now we're in chapter one.
So for the coming slides, Ali or Dean,
please just, if you'd like, select one
bullet point.
Feel free to read the bullet point or
give any remark.
And on these coming slides we're just
going to move through.
But either of you or both of you, please
take the first pass.
All right.
So chapter one introduction.
Dean: I'll let people read through the
slide.
I think the one that we bolded here,
category theory is the mathematics of
pattern, composition, connection and
interaction.
I think you can read that, but I believe
you also have to kind of sit back and ask
yourself, so what does that mean?
So right away they're taking a
superordinate and they're breaking it up
into its parts.
And so again, there's this world within
world within world thing that is
reinforced just in the way that we have
to try to communicate the ideas to the
readers.
Daniel: Awesome and Ali.
Ali: Yes, and I also think the two
problems I find in the first page of
chapter one, namely that each research
group has not only its own language but
also its own perspective, and these
languages and perspectives are not well
connected.
These two issues, I believe, are the
organizing themes of the whole
dissertation.
And we see these issues addressed time
and time again throughout the thesis and
particularly in chapter seven, which
these issues are addressed quite
explicitly, both in terms of the work or
the contribution done in this thesis and
the suggestions for future research.
The other point is that the language of
category theory is homo iconic and can be
used to translate constructions between
contexts.
So again, right at the beginning, this
dissertation tries to put a particular
perspective in order to address the two
issues just mentioned.
So in this case, Toby uses the homo
iconic property of category theory to
address those two issues.
Or more explicitly, category theory
resolves both problems of scientific
translations in this way that concepts
expressed categorically are inevitably
expressed in context and not in
isolation.
And secondly, these contexts are
naturally interconnected as if by a
categorical web with the connections and
expressed categorically.
So in other words, category theory
provides probably the ideal toolkit to
address those situations, those issues,
which I believe is not restricted only to
scientific endeavors.
So these two issues come up in many other
areas and outside science as well.
So in that case, I believe category
theory can provide a much more general
framework to address them, even in non
scientific fields as well.
Dean: Can I just add on to what Ali just
said there real quick?
I agree with you 100%, Allie, about the
toolkit.
And I would add that I also believe it
gives us an opening to develop a rule kit
so that we can actually figure out how to
do that translation piece.
And it also gives us a pool.
I like to use things that rhyme because
it's easy to remember, but the way that
we collect how things congregate, what
that attractor state becomes so that we
can then figure out how things are moving
in that dynamic situation.
So I think it provides a toolkit, a rule
kit, and a pool kit.
Daniel: Great.
All right, next slide on chapter one.
I'll just pick one and then either of you
please.
The one that's exciting to me is we show
that the theory of predictive coding has
a clear compositional structure that
explains the bi directional circuitry
observed in the brain.
So even outside of the connection to the
empirical grounded embodied biology, the
idea that a lot of the ways that in
retrospect, informally, we've been
talking over the last years as a field
and in the institute about the
compositionality of models and can we
just plug in the sense states here to the
action states here?
Can we nest the models these ways?
And the ways that we've been thinking
about the active inference cognitive
kernel like a Lego kit.
All of this is realizing a level of
formality, which doesn't mean
inaccessibility, really quite the
opposite.
That's just accelerating what's possible
with predictive coding.
Bayesian brain active inference free
energy principle.
So we're really seeing like a dawning of
the formal compositionality and to be
able to compose and to be able to
construct are going to have a
relationship that we can continue to
weave in the coming sessions.
Either of you want to highlight some
other piece here?
Dean: I think it's really interesting
because I know that they are trying to
build an infrastructure, but a lot of
this dissertation has to do with a
process that's actually a deconstructor.
deconstructure meaning there's a lot of
pruning and sculpting that they actually
speak to if we were to talk about real
things that form and shape and give us
that sense of what's in and what's out.
So yes, they are building an
infrastructure, but then Toby goes along
and speaks a whole bunch about so why
does this stay and why does this not get
included?
Daniel: Ollie, anything or we'll
continue.
Ali: Just real quick.
It reminds me of Mario Bongay's work on
causality and also Alan Garfinkel's
theory of explanation and particularly in
Garfinkel's work.
In his book Forms of Explanation, he
provides a theory of explanation based on
rigorous modeling of problems in terms of
state spaces and how we can address the
context dependent explanations based on
the contrast space on one hand and the
relevant space on the other.
So category theory, I believe, somehow
unifies, or in other words, translates
these kinds of theories into a rigorous
and coherent framework that can be used
to formalize or rather to frame all of
these theories of explanations and
causalities within a unified framework.
So that's, I believe, one of its greatest
advantages.
Daniel: Great.
Okay, anyone want to give a comment
here?
I'll just give a quick comment, which is
and this is just a peek ahead to chapter
two we're only going to have a few
snippets from the medium, the meso
chapters, the space between.
But don't we see diagrams like this all
the time in active inference with
internal external blanket states, the
particular partition, hierarchical
predictive processing, Bayesian brain
architectures?
We see these diagrams all the time.
And section 2.1 is extremely provocative
with the analysis of neural circuitry and
two other types of systems in really
establishing that the drawing, if it's
informal, is insufficient to completely
convey the argument and to really
represent the situation.
However, if we use the kind of string
diagrams or just diagrams more generally
that category theory provides, we really
get a graphical compositionality that
just drawing on a page, though obviously
wonderful and fun, does not reach.
And so we're going to be able to talk
about how these types of diagrams, which
again we see all over the literature, can
be enriched with this category theoretic
perspective so that we can assess, well,
what if I draw a line from this one over
to that one?
Is that valid?
How is that going to change the
properties?
And so we're going to be able to know a
lot more about that when we understand
the compositional structure via the
Bayesian lenses of these compositional
Bayesian systems.
Anything else to add on this slide?
All right.
Dean or Ali?
Go ahead.
Ali: So chapter one begins with the claim
that the brain's visual circuitry seems
to be roughly hierarchical, and this
hierarchical structure is a hint of
compositionality and thus a sign that a
categorical approach may be helpful and
enlightening.
On the other hand, the underlying
equations of the free energy principle
exhibit a form of compositionality which
is used to obtain the hierarchical
models.
Despite the hint of compositionality, the
equations of motion for these
hierarchical systems are typically
derived from scratch each time a
redundant effort that would not be
required had a compositional formalism,
such as category theory being used from
the start.
So this thesis supplies such a
categorical formalism and exemplifies it
with hierarchical predictive coding under
the free energy principle.
Category theory has a rich formal
vocabulary for precisely describing
universal constructions.
And so not only does a categorical
formulation of.
The free energy framework promise to
clarify the current confusions around
FEP, but it may be expected also to shed
light on its potential universality.
Daniel: Just so exciting and
interesting.
And in terms of the current, the past,
present and future status of the free
energy principle and active inference,
it's an absolutely consequential
direction of work.
Dean, anything here?
Dean: No.
I know that in seven four one, which
we'll talk about later, the introduction
of the term fuzzy and fuzzy distributions
comes up.
So even though they're being precise,
they're being precise, their fuzziness as
well.
Daniel: Great.
Like a high resolution picture of a fuzzy
jacket onwards.
So in this thesis, we do not get as far
as a completely general formulation of
active inference.
And it goes without saying this
expression could be added to every single
thing that we read today.
But in the coming videos and beyond,
we're going to discuss what this all
means and just one more exciting piece
from this page.
Because active inference models and the
free energy framework more broadly are
descriptions of systems that are open to
an environment, interacting with it, and
therefore situated in context, they are
particularly suited to a category
theoretic reformulation.
So that's very exciting because we've
from qualitative philosophical,
humanistic approaches and also from
statistical, numerical, formal
approaches.
We've discussed a lot of this openness
and now we have another entree or another
vector or another toolkit rule kit, pool
kit to work with, and that is just
opening the space up a lot.
Ollie or Dean, want to add anything.
Dean: Here, just real quick?
We've talked in other live streams.
We've used images of ice cream cones and
ice cream trucks and what's in the
foreground and what's in the background,
what's actually the context and what is
the content.
And this reinforces that idea of as the
observer, as the one using their optic
nerves, what did you choose to put in
front and what is in behind?
And we have to keep that in mind because
we shouldn't assume that everybody
chooses the way that we do.
So, again, just making sure we understand
what's being said here in this slide.
It's really important.
Daniel: Thank you, Ali.
Ali: Yes, and I still think it's really
clever to title the dissertation as
mathematical foundations for a
compositional account of the Bayesian
brain as opposed to active Inference.
Because, as we all know, one of the
distinguishing features of active
inference theory and what sets it apart
from other related theories such as
Bayesian brain and predictive coding
theories, is the fundamental integration
of action into perception.
So as long as this dissertation doesn't
provide a full fledged account of this
kind of action integration, I believe it
would be more appropriate to term it as a
compositional account of the Bayesian
brain and not particularly active
inference.
But of course, in chapter seven, toby
suggests some potential ways that this
kind of integration can potentially be
done in the future.
Research.
Daniel: Awesome.
All right.
Chapter One is already foreshadowing the
idea of cognitive maps.
And Toby writes current models of
cognitive maps.
Some are expressed in the language of
approximate variational inference.
We talk about that a lot.
Some are expressed in the language of
reinforcement learning.
Some attempt to combine the two.
We expect that the foundations developed
here will help us unify these accounts.
So how can we be reimagining?
Maps?
Cognitive maps?
Aren't they all?
Alir, Dean, anything else to add here?
All right, and last few selections from
chapter One.
Either of you, please.
What's the first take?
Here?
I'll go first.
Our primary motivation in writing this
thesis is to lay the groundwork for well
typed cognitive science and computational
neuroscience.
It's a very interesting topic about the
implications of well typing and what does
it mean for something to be well typed?
What is a programming language or a
scientific culture or a framework that's
well piped?
The free energy framework, like the
structurally adjacent framework of
compositional game theory, has a strong
flavor of teleology what is that taste
like?
And systems act in order to make their
predictions come true.
We come to this so many times and in so
many ways.
In reinforcement or reward oriented
learning, you have a reward function, and
systems work to maximize reward, whereas
in free energy as a bounding variable or
functional on surprise, the imperative is
to bound and reduce surprise such that
expectations or preferences are
realized.
And so here it's expressed
qualitatively.
We've approached this in many different
paper discussions from a statistical,
numerical, formal, analytical angle, and
here we're approaching it from another
formal avenue of category theory.
And either of you have any comments on
this or want to talk about the last
piece?
Dean: Yeah, I'll talk quickly about
scientific faith.
In the programming that I did, we had a
little axiom or expression that was, if
it isn't history, then it's a mystery.
And I think that's part of what this
scientific faith piece is all about.
I mean, if you have some data, if you
have some way of recording or taking in
or gaining some sense of, that's great,
that's the historical part.
But you still also need that curiosity
and that sense that there is yet still to
be witnessed and observed.
And you have to have some faith that
sticking around is going to be able to
provide that opportunity.
I don't know if a well typed science will
buttress scientific faith.
I think sometimes the personality
matters.
I think if you're the kind of person who
believes in curiosity being resolved and
wayfinding being a really good strategy
to find out who you are and what the
world is about, I think that's the faith
piece that some of us just seem to carry
around, whether we like it or not.
Daniel: Awesome.
Ali, anything on this slide or enclosure
of chapter one?
Ali: Just wanted to mention that by well
typed cognitive science, or more
generally, well typed science.
I believe Toby somehow implying a kind of
more or less claim for disunity of
sciences as opposed to a unified vision
of science.
Because you see, in the unified vision
for science, every explanatory models and
every theory can theoretically be unified
within an overarching principle or
overarching theory, which has not been
discovered yet.
But some philosophers advocate the
position of disunity of sciences.
In other words, although there are some
commonalities between every scientific
areas, but there are some individual
types, or individual concepts, if you
will, that cannot be taken.
I mean, this individuality cannot be
taken for granted simply by just
explaining it away, by proposing some
unifying principle.
So in this sense, well typed science is
quite a rigorous and individualized
notion of scientific endeavor, at least
in my opinion.
But I'm curious to know Toby's opinion.
Daniel: I'll just add one more comment on
the well typed in programming languages
where type safety or type soundness is
being described as a beneficial feature
in certain contexts.
Obviously, people point to the way that a
well typed language can prevent illegal
operations or use safer handling of short
term memory, working memory, and avert
logical errors.
So it's very interesting to think about
what that means in science in terms of
not just the reproducibility of
experimentation, but in terms of what
experiments and what research avenues are
pursued overall, as well as even
cognitive security.
So there's so many different angles where
well typing is going to matter for the
way that we think about compositional,
cognitive cartography, which we're going
to come to.
Now, chapter seven, we skipped over a few
pieces, didn't we?
That's how the last six months felt.
Dean: It was 9900.
Yeah.
Daniel: I'll hold on the jokes for now,
but yeah, we skipped about 200 pages
right there.
That's the part that you want to take
lightly.
That's the bottom of the bathtub.
You jump into chapter one and it's
exciting.
It's like skiing downhill.
And then this vast tundra opens of
chapters two through six, which again was
the last half year for us and several
others.
So now let's get to chapter seven, and
then the sandwich will be dissected with
Toby.
Okay.
With absolute humility and accuracy, toby
points to three prominent shortcomings of
the thesis.
Ali, do you want to summarize these three
shortcomings?
Ali: Sure.
So the first one is that the notion of
approximate inference doctrine should be
tested with further exemplification.
In other words, specifically with the
problem of double counting, which is
addressed in chapter six.
The other one is that the general models
that Toby is considered in this
dissertation are somehow static despite
its application in modeling dynamical
systems.
So again, this problem is addressed.
I mean, some suggestions for overcoming
this shortcoming is addressed in this
chapter, specifically in relation to
Meyer's Categorical theory of dynamical
systems.
And finally, although we consider lower
level neural circuit models, we did not
explicitly connect our approximate
inference doctrines to these more
biological models.
So in other words, it's not a theory for
modeling the whole Iguana, it's just a
modeling framework for modeling a very
specific function or the cognitive
function of the brain.
Dean: I don't know that knowing your
limits should be considered a
shortcoming.
That's just philosophical me going
knowing.
Okay, so of the three of us, I'm the one
guy who's proud to say I get it wrong 20%
of the time.
I don't give a rat's backside most often
about precision and perfection.
I want to try.
And so if somebody says, well, the thing
that I'm talking about here has its
limits and it's not going to solve all
the problems of the world, I just think
that's being realistic and honest.
So call it shortcomings, I see it as a
bit of a feature, being self aware of not
being able to do everything at once.
Daniel: Yeah, so often in papers it's
apologetic when it's actually the
adjacent possible.
And there's always an adjacent possible,
indeed an expanding one.
So to make an exponentially expansive
apology rather than pointing to the
adjacent possible and seeing what can
become is just two sides of the same coin
with a third side being the rim on that
coin.
7.1 structured worlds and 7.1.1 Bayesian
sensor fusion.
Ollie, how do you see sensor fusion?
Ali: Yes, so sensor fusion is a situation
where one has a number of sensors which
report spatially situated data and also
it's kind of a problem of combining the
local data with the global data.
So in category theory there is an obvious
choice for addressing this particular
problem, namely the notion of sheets,
which is a spatially coherent data type,
something like a bundle for which local
sections can always be uniquely glued
together into a global section, as Toby
described here.
And it reminds me of the theory of, I
mean the derivation of the duality
between FEP and CMEP in Bayesian
mechanics paper by deploying these
notions of bundles.
So in other sense, sheath theory and the
related fields of applied topology and
chromology allow us to judge when it is
possible to form a consensus and quantify
the obstructions to the formation of
consensus.
Hence, the consensus between FEP and CMAP
as done in Bayesian mechanics paper, I
believe is done in the same sense of
sheath theory as providing a possibility
for emerging such a consensus.
And also missing from the current chief
theoretic understanding of sensor fusion
is a thorough treatment of belief and
uncertainty, especially from a Bayesian
perspective.
A first possible extension of the work
presented here is to extend statistical
gains and approximate and approximate
inference doctrines and hence the classes
of model that they encompass, to
structured data types such as sheets.
We expect that the first step will be to
consider categories of channels between
sheeps.
Daniel: Awesome.
And just to give a more mundane or
empirical example of sensor fusion, what
if we have many EEG sensors on a head and
we need to synthesize into one joint
representation?
Or what if we have temperature sensors
across an agricultural field and humidity
sensors?
How this happens is called sensor fusion,
and category theory is helping us
understand the compositionality of such
issues.
Dean: Dean yeah, I just want to focus in
on bullet number two here, because,
Daniel, both you and Allie, I think
you're absolutely correct.
I think where they say something like a
bundle for which local sections can
always be uniquely glued together into a
global section.
Well, of course they can, but I don't
know that that's necessarily the magic
what if in a counterfactual sense.
What if they are glued?
Is that something we must commit to?
And then if it is going to be glued
together into some sort of global
composition, when that timing of when to
do that, I also think is something that
we judge.
So is that the data set, the what if and
the when, is that the data set that we're
going to eventually bump into?
I would argue yes.
Does that mean we're going to have to
pass through that moment and come out on
the other side of it, hopefully still
intact?
Yes, to me, that is consensus building.
So I know that that's one little sentence
in a 200 page paper.
But again, there are so many nuggets in
this paper where if you just slow down
and read it and think about what the
implications of what they're saying are,
you could literally go off right there on
that one sentence and spend hours trying
to figure out, okay, so really, what
should we be doing with this?
Is this a priority?
Whatever.
Daniel: Awesome.
Continuing on to address that first
shortcoming, we already mentioned
Sheaves, and we hope that these tools
will suggest new connections to work on
quantum theoretic formulations of the
free energy framework.
That's something we've discussed in
several stream series.
Livestream 17 with Chris Fields on
information flow in context dependent
hierarchical Bayesian inference,
Livestream 40 with Friston, Levin,
Glazebrook and Fields on a free energy
principle for generic quantum systems and
the ongoing Chris Fields course, Physics
as Information Processing 2023.
So category theory and adjacent tools are
already widely utilized in quantum
sciences, quantum information science,
more broadly, quantum computation, and so
on one hand, we see the quantum and free
energy principle synthesis outlined in
these stream series.
And here we have the category theory,
active inference, Bayesian brain, free
energy principle synthesis.
So all three category theory, quantum and
FEP walk into a sheath.
What do they say?
All right, Ali, what is a summary or
overview on learning structure and
structured learning?
Ali: Yes.
So an interesting distinction is provided
right at the beginning between structured
learning and learning structure.
So structured learning, at least Toby,
means extending the process of learning
to a structured setting.
But by learning structure, he means
learning the underlying structures
themselves.
So in the categorical semantics of
dependent type theory, the context is
witnessed by the object over which a
slice category is defined.
And in so in some sense it defines the
shape of the universe by the growth in
the construction.
There is correspondence between sheaves
and certain bundles as objects of slice
categories.
And so we can think of structured
inference and learning as taking place in
appropriate slice categories.
So both of those somehow address the
binary concepts of structured learning
and learning structure in a complementary
way.
So we can think of bundle morphisms as
generalized parameters maps.
And in that case, the problem of learning
structure then becomes a problem of
generalized parameter learning.
And this is the way that some
reinforcement learning techniques have
been deployed by using this kind of
generalized parameter learning.
So we expect this line of inquiry to
clarify the relationships between our
formalism of approximate inference and
other related work on the categorical
foundations of cybernetics which have
typically been studied in a differential
rather than probabilistic setting.
We expect the connection to be made by
information geometry where Bayesian
inference can be understood both using
gradient descent and as a kind of
parallel transport.
In other words, it is a way to unify both
the physical formulation of physical
formulation of system as done through the
differential equations in cybernetics and
also the probabilistic formulation of the
systems as done in Bayesian mechanics.
Daniel: Awesome.
Just two quick notes on this.
First, the growth and deak construction.
Shauna Dobson spoke about this in the
Math Art Guest Stream in the context of
the evolution of art and other areas in
math and philosophy over the last hundred
years with this progressive
swarmification sheafification of self.
So that's really cool to see.
And then we expect the connection to be
made.
What we expect is what we prefer, and
then what we expect prefer is shaping our
action selection to realize it.
So again, once we, as mentioned earlier,
understand that systems act in order to
make their expectations realized, we see
that these kinds of expressions are more
than just the expression of a belief,
they're also in some ways an action
imperative.
Dean, any thoughts?
Dean: I could go for days on this
section, of course, but I will say this
who knew there was so much to be loaded
up between the difference of a verb tense
right structure and structured added D
and all of a sudden we're discretized
between process and product.
I'll just start there and wait for Toby
to come on because I could literally have
a field day.
I'm at the circus, the carnival and every
single theme park in the world when it
comes to this stuff.
Daniel: It's awesome.
All right, now we get to seven one three
compositional, cognitive, cartography
sailing, the three C's.
Ali, what is this section about?
Ali: Okay, so this is mainly addresses
the success of representation and I mean
doing a kind of a comparison between
successive representation and other
cognitive map theories.
In other words, the topus theoretic
developments sketched so far may provide
a suitable setting in which to understand
the neural basis for navigation and help
explain how, ostensibly spatial
navigation processes and circuits are
invariably involved in more abstract
problem solving.
Atopos is not only a richly structured
category of spaces or spatial types, but
it can also be understood as a category
as a categorified space itself.
But an important notion here is that
under the free energy principle, there's
a close relationship between beliefs
about the geometry of an environment and
beliefs about expected future
trajectories in that environment.
So this is basically the idea behind
successor representation of the cognitive
map, which says roughly that the brain's
representation of where it is is
equivalently a representation of where it
soon expects to be.
So under the free energy principle, and
similarly, under the successor
representation, the expected dynamics is
a geodesic flow, which is determined by
beliefs about the spatial geometry.
But crucially, these beliefs are not a
static.
They depend on what the agent believes
will happen.
And this has been suggested as an
explanation for the predictive nature of
the cognitive map.
In other words, if we don't take into
consideration the uncertainty behind the
information available to the agent, then
we wouldn't get to formalize the behavior
in a truly predictive way, because
obviously there isn't any uncertainty to
predict about and then compare the
prediction with the actual data.
The cognitive map has its central locus
in the hippocampus, which we may
therefore understand as representing the
base space over which the big topus is
sliced.
And since changes of plan seem therefore
to induce changes of base, we might see
the functional connectivity of the brain
as witnessing this mathematical
structure.
And this particular claim, I believe, is
maps perhaps perfectly onto Boujaki's
theory of brain from inside out.
So Boujaki provides a kind of theory that
sets the hippocampus as the agential
center of all the cognitive tests that
needs to be reconstructed from inside
out, as opposed to just processing the
coming data in a kind of purely
computational unidirectional way.
Daniel: We talked a lot about, and
certainly will in the coming weeks, about
what is witnessing, how is witness
related to observation, but we'll come
back to that.
Okay, continuing on, on the compositional
cognitive cartography, there's some
discussion about the internal universe of
the topos, not just the Topos institute,
but the concept and the way that the
representations of the cognitive map are
inherently context dependent.
Therefore, it fits naturally within the
subjectivist metaphysics implied by the
free energy framework, a topic that I
know Ali is extremely interested in.
And Dean Ali, any other comments on
this?
Slice?
Maybe we can start calling them a slice
or a bundle instead of a slide.
Dean: Well, if we do go the slice route,
one thing I would just pause for a
second.
I think for most people, in context,
geometry or geometric stability is
usually the association, whereas geodesic
flow, which was mentioned in the last
slide is a lot more dynamic.
And I think that if we're going to talk
about a composition like the flow of the
piece of music that's now playing out, we
have to think of this as both framed and
filtered.
And so these sheaves allow for that sense
of distribution, that movement part, I
think, metaphorically of exploitation and
exploration now being the two passengers
in the HOV Lane and HOV Lanes in North
America at least, are designated by a
diamond.
So you can see how the geometry and the
geodesic again can all be put together,
and you're starting to build a picture in
these different models and maps that you
may be constructing great.
Daniel: 7.2 societies of Systems I'll
just say that a collection of purely
passive agents is no society at all.
What would it even be, Ali?
Want to add anything more on the forwards
and backwards, perhaps, and the
compositional structure?
Ali: Well, first of all, I wanted to just
point that the very first sentence here,
a collection of purely passive agents is
no society also applies to one of my
favorite metaphysical theories out there,
namely the assemblage theory.
So we can say that a collection of purely
passive agents is no assemblage as well.
But in any case, the doctrines of
approximate inference introduced in this
thesis are inherently perceptual.
But the forward channel of a statistical
gain points towards the environment
predicting the expected incoming sense
data, whereas the backwards channel
points from the environment into the
agent, terminating in the agent's most
causally abstract beliefs one way in
which we can incorporate action and
thereby shape the framework of this
thesis into a framework for active
inference.
The forwards channel should predict not
only sense data incoming from the
environment, but also the actions to be
taken by the agent.
So up until now in the dissertation, he
has provided in quite elaborate detail
how this kind of formulation of the bi
directional channels can be used to
reframe the perceptual side of active
inference.
But as I mentioned earlier, he doesn't go
so far as to integrate the action into
this framework as well.
But of course, here is a potential way
forward which we can deploy the same
forward channel as being the actions to
be taken by the environment because of
the same directionality it possesses.
We therefore expect the compositional
theory of active inference to have
forwards channel rather so that an
agent's sensorium depends on the
configuration or quote unquote action
that it has chosen.
And another very, in my opinion,
significant point here is the
substitution of the notion of markup
blankets throughout the whole
dissertation with the notion of
polynomial fontors, because, as have been
discussed in the previous chapters as
well, Markov blanket doesn't provide a
rigorous enough concept to be applied
quite at least directly in category
theory.
So polynomial functions substitute the
well known notion of markup blanket as
used in active inference literature to
characterize basically the same thing or
the interaction boundaries of adaptive
agents.
Daniel: Yes, so many great pieces here.
Markup blanket used in the informal
active inference literature, like
everything we've been studying for the
last few years, all of that casual light,
airy, breezy we had fun.
Now it's time to formalize that.
And there's so much more we can say about
backwards and forwards, but we'll just
carry on.
7.21 active Inference there are some
mentions about the resemblance between
active inference and economic games in
terms of they're both having lenses into
the area or the arena of interaction.
And this line of inquiry naturally leads
onto the consideration of multi agent
systems.
Perhaps this can be investigated with
poly algebras.
7.2.2 what is the type of a plan?
Perception and action are thus in
general, the two dual ways in which a
system can minimize its free energy
change your mind, change the world.
Akin to the two degrees of freedom
available in an autoencoder game
discussed in the thesis a system that
acts must necessarily be motivated
towards some goal and in order to realize
its goal, the system must enact a plan.
Dean, pick it up from here.
Dean: Well, I will just say this I'm not
going to speak to the stuff on the slide
necessarily.
At the very end of this section, Toby
writes this prompts us to ask what is the
form of this data and how can we
incorporate it into the compositional
framework?
In other words, what is the type of a
plan?
These seem to us to be key questions for
future work.
This prompted me to go and then we wonder
why teachers struggle sometimes to
necessarily remember what it was like to
be the learner.
Because we can come up with a plan.
Because we've done the learning.
We're now the learned, right?
The learner now changes because of one
tense present to past tense change.
Or why the plan that we put before
learners removes all the critical work
for self organizing.
This is the cost of being a teacher.
Because if we do the planning for
somebody and I understand why we have to
do it, because if they're walking into a
space, we don't want them falling off
jumping off cliffs necessarily and not
having a soft landing.
However, we do need to talk a little bit
about what is the type of a plan and what
are the benefits and the costs of
choosing to use that strategy going
forward, especially if we're in the role
of somebody who's supposed to be guiding,
opening up worlds, horizons and all that
other stuff.
Daniel: Thank you.
Ollie, any other comments on this
section?
Ali: Not at the moment.
Daniel: One piece to me is it seems
unnecessarily crude to hide all of this
data, which is described as a lot of
data, inside of a single undifferentiated
choice of prior distributions.
So that's very interesting in light of,
again, the statistical, numerical,
quantitative way that we've approached
policy selection as inference planning as
inference action and inference.
What does it mean to differentiate this
choice?
Okay, reinforcement learning, open games
and ecosystems.
Ali, any summary here?
Ali: Okay, so as also indicated in the
first sentence, there is a close
relationship between active inference
theory, markup decision problems and
reinforcement learning as explored
numerous times before in many papers.
But the standard algorithm for gaining an
optimality for policy selection is
usually called backward induction in
reinforcement learning, or Akas dynamic
programming.
So namely, backward induction is
structured according to a similar bi
directional pattern, or the optic pattern
to that of both Bayesian inference and
reverse differentiation, and that MDPs
themselves fit into the associated
general framework of open games.
So in the informal active inference
approach to MDPs, the system in question
counterfactually evaluates policies using
a backward induction like process,
accumulating free energies in order to
score them.
Now, in this process, it is this process
that results in the prior that we're all
familiar with in active inference
context, which is then updated by the
agents inference process.
But future work will need to untangle
this not of interrelated bi directional
process, in other words, how we can
explicitly determine in what way those
kinds of processes, although being quite
in a quite different opposite
directionality, can be unified into a
unified framework.
So we hope that having done so, we will
show how the whole picture emerges and
how it relates to the developing
geometric or diegetic framework in
categorical cybernetics, possibly
involving the further development of our
notion of cilia.
Daniel: Great.
Continuing on with reinforcement
learning, open games, and ecosystems.
Since the free energy principle
underlying active inference asserts a
certain informal universality, we might
also hope that the satisfactory
development of compositional active
inference might exhibit a universal
property that any other doctrine of
cybernetic systems factors uniquely
through it.
There's some discussion of multiagent
systems and their implied global search.
Casting this account into the emerging
framework of compositional active
inference will point towards a bridge to
multiagent reinforcement learning.
The resulting general account of
multiagent intelligence will encompass
both reinforcement learning and active
inference, allowing us to understand
their relative strengths and difference.
We hope that one distal outcome of the
work will be a new and beneficial
understanding of corporate activity,
sometimes called organizational
cybernetics or metagovernance.
We should expect any framework resulting
from this work to capture existing models
of collective active inference, such as
recent work on spin glasses or ant
colonies.
Any other thoughts on this?
Dean: Yes, Dean, I know that this is my
biases literally on the surface, but I
believe that the idea of open games and
opened P-E-N-E-D ecosystems is a future
path that a lot of formalized and
structured learning is going to take.
It's the work that I did essentially for
ten years.
And so I think that everything that
you're seeing here may become a new model
that can be optioned into in terms of how
you would.
Want to structure your learning.
So I think this is really important
stuff.
Daniel: How you'd like to structure your
learning and how you'd like to learn
structure exactly.
7.3.
The mathematics of Life we move on to
consider the relationships between
compositional active inference and the
contemporary mathematics of life.
We hope that compositional active
inference may supply part of the story of
a modern theory of autopoiesis the
ability for life to recreate itself.
So just some brief notes on topics that
are near and dear to us as we get close
to the end.
7.3.1.
Bayesian mechanics and the free energy
principle.
Recently it has been suggested in various
venues citation 53 and 54 Karl Friston
2019 a free Energy Principle for a
Particular Physics and fort.
54 Par DeCosta and Friston Markov
blanket's information geometry and
stochastic thermodynamics that the free
energy framework provides a universal way
to understand the behavior of adaptive
systems.
Bayesian mechanics promises to build upon
the nascent understanding of random
dynamics via inference.
245, 245 dalton's activity Bell towards a
Geometry and Analysis for Bayesian
Mechanics and Ramstead et al.
On Bayesian mechanics, a physics of and
by beliefs.
Also check out Livestream number 49 to
supply a new theory of mechanics for
statistical systems.
The present formulation of Bayesian
mechanics is constructed using
mathematical tools from physics, but not
yet the kinds of compositional tools
promoted in this thesis.
We expect that developments along the
lines sketched here will unify the
ongoing developments of Bayesian
mechanics with the new synthetic
understanding of mathematical physics by
casting all dynamics as abstract
inference.
We should also expect this line of
inquiry to begin to quantify the
persistence of things and imbue much of
physics within elon vital with a vital
energy.
Any thoughts on this?
Dean: Okay, well, I was just going to say
I think that section you've already
talked about the importance of
adjunction, and this section literally
makes that very clear.
I think that the relation and the
translation are kind of the on and
through of this part of where the
Bayesian mechanics and the free energy
principle help us understand that there
is a statistical game that's also
strategic.
Again, I'll be interested to talk to.
Daniel: Toby about that great carrying on
with mathematics life seven, three, two
biosemiotics Ali, want to give any
summary or thoughts on biosimiotics?
Ali: Sure.
So the emerging biosymiotic
reconceptualization of life explicitly
acknowledges the importance and
universality of communication in context,
proposing that in any such situation, the
interpreting system necessarily has an
internal representation of the external
world, so to speak, its own belt, which
is updated by interpreting incoming
signals.
We can in principle reconstruct the
external world by understanding it as
that which a collection of systems agrees
about.
Perhaps then, the shared universe, as
determined topus theoretically of a
fusion of active inference agents is a
good model of this semi sphere.
It seems therefore, that mathematics
resulting from our work on internal
universes and their interactions and more
broadly, many of the formal ingredients
of compositional active inference is well
aligned with the informal structures of
biosymiotics, and so it may be desirable
to reexpress biosymiotics accordingly.
In doing so, perhaps the mathematics of a
modern Bayesian subjectivist metaphysics
will be found, for instance, by
expressing communication and its
phenomenology as a geometric morphism, a
generalized base change between agents
internal universes.
And it might be worth mentioning here the
work of people like Terrence Deacon and
also Karen Broad's agential Realism.
Because in Terrence Deacon's work, and
particularly in his book called
Incomplete Nature, he provides a kind of
nested hierarchy.
Of how various kinds of informations as
provided to biological organisms are
structured in a nested, hierarchical way
that would allow the agent to distinguish
the purely informational data as opposed
to the semantic data that is, in the
innermost level of the nested hierarchy.
And also, Karen broad's agential realism
provides this notion of intra action,
which allow the agent or the system of
interest to co constitute itself via the
very interaction with the environment.
So it's not just pure interaction between
the system and its environment, but
rather both the agent and the environment
co constitutes themselves through the
intra action.
So it might be worth exploring some of
these ideas with Toby as well.
Daniel: Dean, anything to add on this
one?
Dean: No, I think Ali summed it up
perfectly.
Daniel: All right.
And the final section Fundamental Theory
future work connected to this thesis need
not only be an application.
A number of purely theoretical questions
raise themselves too.
So for people who we could already hear
in the live chat in the YouTube comments
complaining that this was too practical,
too application oriented, don't worry.
There's also some theoretical questions
that raise themselves so first, geometric
methods for structured belief updating
the mathematics of belief is in large
part about replacing definite points with
Fuzzier distributions over them.
In fact, this PDF copy error with a fuzzy
interpretive system allows the word to be
read by a human independent type theory.
We replace points with terms.
Non dependent terms are exactly points.
So a type theory with belief should
somehow encompass fuzzy terms.
We might well want to express beliefs
about things whose identity we are not
quite sure.
Seven four two dynamics.
Chapter five supplies the beginnings of a
compositional coalgebraic theory for
open, stochastic and random dynamical
systems in general time.
And we hope that this theory could
provide a home for a modern account of
nonequilibrium systems.
Home, home on the state space.
And seven four three computation.
A new understanding of computation may
follow the semiotic understanding of
information processing that we propose
above.
Perhaps we could say more precisely that
computation is the dynamics of semiosis.
The time is right for such a
reconceptualization, as human made
systems increasingly move away from von
Neumann architectures towards more
biosimilar ones such as Mem risters
optical processors, Neuromorphic
technology, graph processors, or even
many core and mesh based evolutions of
classical processors.
So some absolutely fantastic theoretical
avenues to pursue.
Any of you want to comment on some of
these avenues?
Dean, please.
Dean: In the dynamics section, there's a
really interesting, again, more
confirmation bias in my world.
He says here, chapter five has supplied
the beginnings of the composition of
Coalgebraic theory for open, stochastic
and random dynamical systems in general
time.
Me being a time guy.
That's cool.
And we hope that this theory could
provide a home for a modern account of
non equilibrium systems with category
polynomial functions, applying a
satisfactory account of these systems.
And then I'm going to slow down because
this is the part that I really like.
Interfaces in brackets, I e, the
boundaries across which information flows
along and in the word along, there's the
word on in the middle, which they compose
and through which they interact, and me
being an on and through being the same
thing.
This was fantastic confirmation of that
in a dynamic sense.
Daniel: And Ali.
Ali: Yes.
And also, again, I think some of the work
done by Bob Coke and his colleagues
regarding the Bayesian quantum inference
and especially proposing a kind of string
diagrams in the sense of using category
theory to explore the whole theory of the
quantum Bayesian inference.
I believe it maps unto this sense of
dynamics as provided by Toby in the final
pages of his dissertation.
In the case that in the basing quantum
inference, it is also a question.
Of how to provide the exact time
evolution of each state or each agent.
Not strictly in a linear sense, but both
in linear and sorry in the predictive and
also the retroactive sense.
In other words, by taking into account
the whole arrow of time, not just a
particular instant or particular moment
of it.
So in the sense, I think the discussion
of non equilibrium systems, which is
still an underexplored area of physics,
by using category theory, can help to
unify or at least make connections
between these kinds of predictive models
as used in classical physics and also
some of the retroactive models as
recently proposed in quantum Bayesian
theory.
Daniel: Great.
And so we couldn't escape without showing
at least a little bit of a hint of what
realistically much of the dissertation
looks like.
So next time we're going to jump into the
thick of it.
These kinds of equations and diagrams are
what you're going to find when you unpack
the dissertation.
And of course, there's so much to add and
we did so much work on just scratching
the surface of what these diagrams are
and how they actually convey formality in
category theory.
And it's going to be great to work and
talk together on them.
And with Toby, where does that leave us,
fellows?
Dean with the pre penultimate thought and
then Ollie?
Dean: Well, I think that there's going to
be a big shift from today's Livestream.
Ali: Which.
Dean: Tries to be gentle on us, but also
anybody who's really curious as to where
this goes next.
I think it's going to be a lot more
sophisticated and there's going to be a
little bit more work to do, but I think
at least we've started down a path that
hopefully we've piqued your curiosity.
As the last question says, what are you
still curious about?
I think there's a lot coming up that
should be pretty good for those that want
to really dig now into the real
formalisms and the real structure of
this.
Daniel: Thank you, Dean.
Ali?
Ali: Well, at the end of our six month
joyful ride through this dissertation, I
believe, at least from a personal point
of view, I truly learned a lot and it
piqued my interest in lots of domains and
areas which I didn't know I have interest
in them before.
So I think it's really a good mark of an
influential work, be it dissertation or a
book or paper or any other kinds of
academic publication to peak people's
mind, to explore in even some unexplored
areas and try to connect the dots in
particular in the category theory sense,
in a very rigorous, well typed and even
insightful ways.
And maybe some exciting developments and
results can emerge from these kinds of
dot connections.
Daniel: Thank you both for this excellent
stream.
I have so much gratitude for the whole
category theory team, not just the
sheaves around Toby that enable and
scaffold this work, but also the way that
we were able to collaborate over the last
months and in the bigger picture, maybe
the end of a chapter.
We just finished chapter one or chapter
zero, and that's really what the dot zero
is.
So we were in the dot.
Now we are bringing the dot zero to a
closure.
Soon we're going to jump into the dot one
and the dot two with Toby and even that
in some other nested scale is AOO or a
dot zero.
So thank you again, Ali and Dean et al.
Till next time.
Dean: Thank you.